from the national review
anthony fauci plans to step down in
december that's it he wrote a big long
thing saying i will be leaving these
positions in december of this year to
pursue the next chapter of my career
he's 81 what's the next chapter of your
career i'm trying to be a dick or
anything but it's like bro get your
rocking chair sit on your porch rock
back and forth with a nice sweet tea and
enjoy and enjoy your sunny days man but
he's saying he's still got a lot to do
now the the big thing here is let me see
if i have it pulled up
newsweek writes fouchy resigning out of
fear of gop investigations say
republicans
in december fauci will forfeit his roles
as the chief of the niaid laboratory of
immuno regulation and president joe
biden's chief medical advisor saying he
wants to pursue the next chapter of my
career republicans believe fauci is
leaving government due to the
possibility that the gop will take
control of the house in november quote
dr fauci is conveniently resigning from
his position in december before house
republicans have an opportunity to hold
him accountable for destroying our
country over these past three years the
republican rep andy biggs of arizona
tweeted
adding that fauci will be held
accountable whether or not he remains in
public office this guy is a coward well
maybe that's the case but if he's not
actively in government and they start
investigating him it won't disrupt
whatever those those uh institutions are
actually doing so
either way
this is this move will absolutely help
joe biden's administration over the next
couple of years and the nia niaid but
i'm curious joe considering you're
actually i mean surgeon general you're
like the top doctor of florida right as
crazy as it sounds i mean i have to
pinch myself i am literally the top
doctor of florida which is kind of nuts
well what do you think about this you
think his resignation is just career
stuff uh what do you think about fauci
well you know
i think dr falchi is a
creepy guy he'll be totally honest he
gives me the creeps
you know i think that
he's you know he he's he is
enigmatic of a of a
physician who
is really more of a politician
and more
about
you know sort of agendas
than about health i mean that's been
very obvious with how he handled the
pandemic not a single word right you
have a condition where obesity is a
major risk factor did he ever say hey
americans by the way you know lose
weight if you're overweight get some
exercise i didn't hear that out of his
health he did once say vitamin d though
he he did say vitamin d is important he
did say that once and he said that once
and never again
right yeah right that is that is the
creepiest thing to me about a lot of
this uh is that
during the pandemic people had had
pointed out quite extensively vitamin d
you know getting sunlight getting
exercise getting fresh air and these
things were really important but this
was never the official guidance it was
never the narrative in fact was quite
the opposite stay inside don't go
outside and in big cities they locked
everybody in their homes yeah no
absolutely and you know there's some
controversy over vitamin d but it's not
killing anyone so it was the right thing
to do what's the vitamin d controversy
well it's you know vitamin d is very
mysterious because
there is study after study that shows
that if you have low levels of vitamin d
you're at higher risk for everything
depression high blood pressure cancer i
mean you name it infection
but the clinical trials have not usually
shown
what the other studies have shown not
all of them though some of them have
shown a reduction in infection actually
with vitamin d pre-pandemic
but it again it's it's very interesting
the studies go both ways
and
what what gets me actually is that
you know
maybe it doesn't work but there's like
there's a class of doctors who are just
rabid about trying to stop people from
using medications that are low risk and
you know and are uncertain well they're
just they just want to keep saying no
that doesn't work no that doesn't work
there's actually
i don't want to get too nerdy but
fluvoxamine is a medication that had a
couple clinical trials that showed
benefit in covid and i i recommended it
you know i recommended it to patients
because there was data
but you know another trial just came out
that didn't find a benefit and
the journey the writers at the new
england journal medicine slam this
medication but the problem is the
medication was dosed at like 50 of the
dose that worked
so how can you slam how can you conclude
that something doesn't work when you're
not even dosing it right but they're
just crazy about concluding things don't
work and telling people not to use stuff
what was what was the one you just
mentioned
fluvoxamine fluvoxamine what is that
actually it's it's a medication for like
anxiety
and it just so happens that one of the
ways it works
is on a receptor that is also needed by
the virus so a few clinical trials have
shown that it benefits people but so
this is not an official treatment it's
not approved or anything like that it's
not an official treatment the fda
actually reviewed it recently and they
decided not to give it the thumbs up
and you know that was criticized by some
advocates of the of the medication and
you know the fda it wasn't that they
didn't make the right decision but they
took forever to make the decision and
this thing we could have had the answer
to this like two years ago literally but
there was you know there was very little
interest in treatment during the
pandemic as well i think people know
there's there's there are several
treatments that um have become you know
notorious
and
youtube explicitly bans people for for
uh advocating for and things like that
the strange thing to me about a lot of
it is
if if the argument was always talk to
your doctor
why is it that if if a doctor recommends
something publicly it's unacceptable and
it's abandonable look i understand this
there will there's a lot of crazy people
saying a lot of crazy things online and
i can understand there's a fear that
during a pandemic someone's telling you
to do something wacky or wild and
you know they wanna they wanna control
that but you can't that's that's the
thing like you literally can't you've
got a bunch of doctors who are like i'm
a doctor here's what i recommend and
they're like you're banned and it's like
but fauci's not practicing is that
correct like he wasn't practicing for 30
years i don't think he still sees
patients certainly not actively or
frequently
so the issue i take with fauci over the
past several years
um notably during the peak of the
pandemic was the wishy-washiness the
flip-flopping yeah which which he
justified as well the science is
changing oh gosh he don't justify
anything that guy i mean he's so
slippery and slick i he just
he's completely dishonest it's ironic
that so many americans trust him and he
is probably one of the least trustworthy
doctors i've ever you know observed in
my life but he's not even my
understanding not practicing for a very
very long time he's a bureaucrat more
than anything oh that's for sure but
he's coming off on tv as if he is the
expert and because of the things he says
you end up with these really weird
tribalist positions where very famously
early on he said don't wear masks
later on he said the reason they were
saying that is because they needed the
masks for the nurses and the doctors and
it was more important they got it and it
was like so which is it you know were
you did the science change or were you
aware and you didn't want people buying
masks
either way you cut it all right he's
dishonest by the way the science didn't
change but either way you cut it he's
dishonest because the thing is the
clinical trials before the pandemic
almost all of them found no benefit from
regular folks walking around with masks
i'm not talking about hospitals i'm
talking about walking around the city
like you see you're going the grocery
store wearing a mask so that's what the
studies showed so the rationale behind
what that was flipping
then why did he change his position
that's a great question i mean you know
he what he said of course was that he
was trying to save the masks for health
care workers but how can you even
believe i mean it's hard to well so i'll
i'll say this uh we we've had we've had
conversations about masks before um
we're outside of all of this pandemic
stuff now so i don't know where any any
of like youtube's policies sit on this
stuff but uh we've pulled up the cdc's
website and it actually
it's not as crazy as p as a lot of you
know there's there's the pro-mass people
and the anti-mass people it's actually
decently
i mean moderate when it comes to masks
like the cdc said there's a marginal
benefit it's decent enough that they
would recommend it in some circumstances
like the obvious thing i would say you
know obviously if you're sick and you're
wearing a mask you're going to stop some
coughing sneezing and spitting on people
and something like that right sure
but that's different from whether
wearing a mask reduces the chance of
someone else getting a virus
and even you know i get it like the idea
that you think something's gonna work
and therefore it should work but that's
why we have clinical studies right well
but the cdc on their website now says
that there was a moderate reduction in
like 70 different studies this is the
last time we pulled up this huge list of
studies there yeah i know and this so
this is this is dishonest science
because what you know i i mentioned
vitamin d earlier right so you've got
your observational studies that always
find a relationship where at the low
levels and bad health outcomes and then
you've got your clinical trials that
unfortunately most of the time haven't
found a benefit
the same thing goes for masks they pull
up these observational studies and they
hang their hats on them and the
observational studies are finding these
huge reductions and they and then they
say oh look at this the masks work great
you know and and make those you know
everyone should wear them including kids
like the most ridiculous part i've got
little kids myself
but then you look at the we did there
were during the pandemic there were at
least two large clinical trials
one found zip zero no benefit the second
one was found was it was it was a
denmark
pardon was that also an observational
stuff no no this was a clinical trial
like this is you know you randomize
people you give you know and you you
that's that's the gold standard for
testing stuff whether something actually
works
that's how you know if it really works
and it should work in a clinical trial
too
and one study found zero no benefit
there was so much spin by the way when
that study came out by medical doctors
trying to explain why there wasn't a
benefit
the second study basically found no
benefit there was no benefit for a cloth
mask zero none whatsoever for surgical
mass there was like a 10 reduction so
you know
12
versus 11 of people tested positive like
this is the thing that they're letting
people fight over in airports about and
then for young people there was zero
benefit whatsoever in the second study
so it's a it's a it's a big lie i mean
they're not it's not like they don't
know what evidence is that's what
evidence is well so let me let me pull
up this from uh los angeles daily news
mask mandate didn't work against covet
19 in la say doctors from usc and ucla
letter from doctors said masking had
limited effect and it's best to stress
vaccines other doctors still back masks
i think that the one of the biggest
problems we have right now is uh youtube
censorship policies
what i mean how do you even have a
conversation on science if science
changes if you're not allowed to discuss
science changing dr fauci came out early
on and said not to wear masks he then
came back later and said okay now we're
masks now we have usc and ucla saying
the mandates didn't actually do anything
to stop this so my question is
how can youtube set a censorship policy
when ucla and usc has has issued these
statements like this right i mean it's
it's an untenable situation you can't
even have a public conversation about
how how are we supposed to address any
of this stuff how are we supposed to
function as a society
if that is how big tech is handling it
yeah i totally agree with you you know
their agenda seems
it seems more political for my
perspective from everything i've seen
and you know and i mean i think it's a
pretty rotten system i think it's hurt
people
you know it's not a business that's
going very well for them in terms of
regulating knowledge and opinions well
so where does fuji go from here what do
you guys think
when i came in i said you know what what
the the number one indication that of
why someone is resigning is because they
failed i don't know if that's why he's
resigning because he's now admitting
defeat and failure if he's realized i've
come to the point in my career where i
can no longer serve i'm resigning like
doing the right thing maybe he's doing
the right thing you probably write a
book
i think he could do any number of things
he is entitled to i think the largest
retirement pack package in federal
history because he's the highest paid
federal government employee uh that's
like a study from open the books or a
report from open the books in december
of 2021 i covered it for our site um so
in some ways it is interesting to me
that he is not opting to retire because
he'd still make a lot of money off of
retiring in some ways to me it's hard
not to read vanity into this retiring
means that you're old and retiring means
that you like are no longer supposed to
have an opinion and right now he wields
a lot of influence so if he retires he
is acting as if he's going to step back
and he doesn't want to i mean this is
the man who while by the pandemic filmed
a
documentary about himself with disney
it's a
it doesn't seem like he knows where he
wants to go but he does not want to
leave the limelight and of course that's
subjective although
retiring does seem like a totally
plausible option for him he did i think
i was talking about this before the show
in july there's this report from
politico he'd done this interview and
politico reported that fauci intended to
retire at the end of biden's
administration so that would be next
december not this one and then the day
after they published he was like no i'm
not going to retire what do you mean i
didn't say that even though they have
him on record saying that so it seems
like again this idea of retiring
has a lot of fear for him and whether
it's because he thinks he opens the door
for an investigation or it's a vanity
it's hard to say are you saying that he
could have stayed at the job longer and
then retired and got a monetary package
but yeah he's entitled to a government
pension and because he's been working
for the federal government for i think
four decades uh it's very sizable and
even though he's resigning is he still
getting the same package i believe he
still has access to it but again he's
not publicly retiring and to me that
speaks to vanity he doesn't want to seem
like the old out of touch doctor i wanna
i wanna i wanna ask real quick cause i
don't wanna stick around on the subject
too much but i pulled up the cdc.gov and
they they mentioned so explain to me
what these studies mean it says a large
this is from the cdc the cdc still
recommends wearing masks if you're going
to be in large gatherings this is a
large well-designed cluster randomized
trial in bangladesh in late 2020 found
that surgical or cloth mask mask
distribution
role modeling and active mass promotion
tripled the mass use by 42.3 percent in
intervention villages compared to 13
in villages receiving mask interventions
symptomatic sero provence of sars cover
2 was reduced by approximately 9
relative to comparison villages in
villages randomized to receive surgical
masks symptomatic sero prevalence of
soros coveted two was significantly
lower 11.1 overall the results of the
study showed that even modest increases
in community use can effectively reduce
symptomatic sars covered to infections
so
that that sounds like they do you know
like i was saying you know the cdc says
it's marginal nine to ten percent i mean
that's good though right
so that's not good like so
so that nine or ten percent so the
serial prevalence that they mentioned
what does that mean by the way serial
prevalence so they test people's blood
for antibodies to the virus as an
indicator of prior infection
right
so so nine or ten percent that's called
eight that's a relative reduction so if
you have
the villages that get the the villages
that get the masks and their zero
prevalence is is 12
and you have the villages that don't get
the masks and their zero prevalence is
11
that's a 10 reduction
oh 10 of 12 is one yeah right that's
some lazy that's something so that is
what happened
that's what happened and that by the way
is just another just that's just an
example of the of why you know doctors
like
myself and i think probably some of the
other doctors you've had on your show
are just are are just
fed up with the lies and the
misrepresentation of science that is
exactly what you're familiar with the
study you're saying oh yeah that's
that's the second clinical trial that i
mentioned that's so this is not what the
cdc says though i mean
well they're saying that you went from
12 percent to 11
and that was a significant that shows
that it makes a big difference because
it doesn't mention the 12 percent it
just says that
uh kovid
sarah valence in villages with masks was
reduced by nine percent and villages
randomized to receive surgical masks it
was down 11.1 percent
right right so that's a relative
reduction and i just happened to
remember from reading the study that the
cereal prevalence it was in the teens
right so there was like a one percentage
point difference
in the prevalence that's the fact i mean
that's what that exactly yeah because it
sounds like it's going from 22. hold on
hold on even gets worse this is funny it
sounds like you're saying masks work
well actually gets worse than that so we
have a threshold in in
health policy and epidemiology and
statistics for when we consider a
difference as being significant
you know it's kind of arbitrary but
that's how things work so that threshold
in that study like if this is a
threshold right say we were checking you
know say we were testing the effect of
exercise on
heart disease right
you know if this is a threshold you
compare people that exercise people who
don't like you're like way below the
threshold it clearly is beneficial for
health
the threshold for that study was right
here
it was barely significant
they were they l they barely reached
significance i mean that is an extremely
weak finding well i can only i can only
say that you know the cdc
still has on their website the
recommendation and several studies but i
don't know how to reconcile that with
the news guard certified los angeles
daily news saying that scientists
doctors from usc and ucla saying that
the masks uh that mass masking had a
limited effect it sounds like they're
saying more in line with what you're
saying in fact you were at ucla i
believe i was at ucla and what they're
saying is factual
based on the data maybe they work a lot
better but that hasn't been shown from
clinical trials is there uh evidence
that if you have a dirty mask with like
fecal mech like just gross up that and
you breathe it in that it'll make you
sick
i'm laughing at the people i don't know
why you want to picture bacteria let's
talk about it
well if you have fecal stuff on your
mask you probably will get sick
halitosis
well there you know the actually there
are some studies that show some evidence
of of harm potential harm you know they
don't get a lot of they don't get any
media attention but there are some
studies that show harm in fact
there was a clinical trial of cloth
masks among doctors health care workers
in thailand i think it was thailand that
was published years ago in the british
medical journal which is a very good
journal they compared cloth masks to
surgical masks and basically the people
in this cloth mask group got more
infections
like it seemed that something about it
seemed to increase their is it is it is
it fair to say though you got to be
careful about like a single study that
comes out you know you want to see it
mult the the test like you want to see
the results absolutely in science
absolutely absolutely you mentioned
observational studies how do those work
exactly relative to like a clinical
trial well clinical trial is great
because you you bring people in and you
say
that okay these people they're going to
get the intervention
these people are not and you kind of you
follow them and you see what happens i
mean that's the gold standard
observational studies you know you go
around this room and you measure
let's say you measure um you know what's
a good one for this room uh
sugar consumption
let's do it yeah okay so you measure
sugar consumption and you have each one
of us go out and skateboard okay
so
you know i i i don't know let's suppose
that i don't drink i don't have my sugar
consumption or energy drink consumption
okay
so you so you got guys like me who
basically don't consume energy drinks
say one of you guys do and let's say
that tim consumes a lot of energy drinks
and then you like you go and see how
well we skateboard or we feel some
survey that says how well we skateboard
and then you conclude that hey look at
that you drink more energy drinks you're
going to be a better skateboarder that's
how observational studies work so
they're not they're not like taking into
account he might have been practicing
skateboarding right at the same time
i ate a burrito beforehand
and therefore with that you have
different quality studies like something
that might be better so i think you know
with observational studies you would
need substantially more and all you'd
really do it sounds like is find
anomalies find things that may be that
you'd want to test further that's
exactly right you have to be very very
careful yeah very very careful i mean
the there's so many examples of
misdirection from observational studies
in regards to vitamin d which we brought
up earlier is there a difference i've
heard there's a difference in endogenous
vitamin d and vitamin d that you take
meaning the vitamin d you get your body
to produce naturally from like sunlight
causing it to happen as opposed to
eating a vitamin d uh vitamin is there a
difference in the way it biochemically
interacts
so
you know biochemically not sure i mean
the process by which they it's you know
when your body creates vitamin d versus
taking it from a pill i mean that is
different biologically
but
you know in terms of things like if you
break your wrist or something and it's
because you've got you know low bone
density
whether you take supplemental vitamin d
or you get more sunlight
the benefits of the vitamin d to your
bones are going to be the same
but there are people who believe that
there are differences in the effects
from whether it's sunlight or from a
pill thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there